does my hair look beautiful though your
hair looks beautiful
yes my titties look right everything
looks right mark tell me mark
no you think i can knock a boy off right
now i know you i'm like a geisha girl
like i just like to see
if i could do it still you know like i
still got it
you still got it baby i still got it
all right martina yes martina where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
i'm from sacramento california
and um you know northern california you
know
raised in sacramento you know met kenny
red he's a bay area cat
so that brought me to the bay area you
know that's where i got a lot of my
money
from san francisco you know all up and
down the coast of california
you know i got money all over the world
but you know just starting in the game
all up and down the coast to california
all right and tell me about your family
you had both your parents when you were
young
yes i had both of my parents when i was
young and
um but my father my mom and father split
up but
my mom worked like three jobs but i had
two other brothers that were pimps
so i was like exposed to the game to the
ism
at a young age you know and um
i learned how to speak ism you know real
early in the game
and um you know i always knew to break
on a boy like don't
ever let a boy kiss you or have sex with
you
if you get money from them they won't
tell nobody you know but
it sounds crazy but you know when you're
young you're absorbing all kind of game
from
your big brothers telling their girls
you know what i'm saying they're hoes
you know certain things you know i'm
getting all the game i'm absorbing it
all
so yeah so yeah i always and it's not
it's not it's you know
it's it's it's in me not on me you know
so what age did you start
doing this kind of work well
i think i was in the seventh grade is
the first time i gave a boy
a kiss for fifty dollars but you know i
was 20 years old when i started
you know getting down getting down but i
always been the type like a little gold
digger
when i was a young girl like always
wanted
everything or if you didn't have
anything for me i didn't want to talk to
you
so money money is an important part of
this money money is a very important
part of my life like what's more
important money or love
um sock it to a [ __ ] pocket
[ __ ] love i'm married to the game
first first so you've had uh you've had
pimps along the way
yeah um kenny red um i was with kenny
redd for years
and um
he got me from this uh this older guy
you know god bless him he passed away
and um i was young and um
yeah then i got with kenny red pimping
and he had like
a lot of hoes he you know he was like
exciting he was fun he was just he was
raw he was sharp you know
he was no nonsense and um you know i got
with him
you know but what is the attraction for
a girl to go with a pimp i mean
you're giving him all your money right
well the reason why i did because
he had all kinds of stuff he had you
know a lot of things it wasn't like i
was getting it out the dirt with him
when i got with kenny kenny had
everything you know he had holes you
know what i'm saying he had
thieves he had cars he was just you know
he just had everything you know and i
was just excited by it
and i wanted to be a part of his
organization and where did you get out
of the equation
when did i get out what what did you get
out of the arrange the
relationship what did i get out of it um
i got a lot of stuff out of it most of
all i got
some game up out of it and um a lot of
intelligence from it you know i learned
a lot you know if it's not a blessing
it's a lesson
and um [ __ ] my [ __ ] made me a better
[ __ ] with you it made me a better
person
you know some [ __ ] out here [ __ ]
for free and doing all kinds of stuff i
can go to sleep real good
knowing that i got paid for my [ __ ]
and i use protection on top of that
you know so you've had uh runnings with
the law
i had run-ins with the law and i know
how to swindle my way out of it
and sometimes i can't and when i came
you know what i'm saying
kenny never left me in jail he's coming
to get me he's coming to get in
all his hoes you know what i'm saying he
ain't never left a [ __ ] in jail
ever do you have children of your own
yes i do have a daughter
i'm 55 right now i'm 50 fine
i have a daughter that's 38 years old
she
um is a a college graduate
she has her degrees and everything can
you raise her i raised her
and her father did and he's gone now pat
god bless his soul but um
she respect the game and everything but
that wasn't a path that she chose to
take or anything and i always hid it
from her too you know
i always kept her in boarding schools
and private schools and
she always had the best of everything so
she never knew that you were doing this
for a minute but then then she found out
you know kids are smart and they could
tell
and yes she knew what it was but she
wouldn't trip him because
you know i was around you know players
and pimps and
you know dope dealers and boosters and
you know
we're around that type of people you
don't understand but we were living a
good life it wasn't like we was living
in the gutter we lived in the best
condos and
had the nicest cars and you know
everything
so she know that you know
it was some something jumping off but
you know kids staying chill you know
they
and children stay in children's place so
what what
what what keeps you in in in this
lifestyle is it
is it that the money is is is good and
fast is it that uh oh i'm retired from
that
you know i'm retired from that i have
been a madam
you know i have my own stable but not
even like i'm a pimp or something like
that i just charge service fees
for me accommodating a girl with
a client so i would never put that you
know on me a pimp or anything like that
but i can't say a madam
you know but you know getting my service
fees and all that but
um but for a typical girl that or a guy
that stays in this
game for a long time is it like an
addictive lifestyle that just
it's very addictive the game be calling
your name it'd be like
martina martina
but you just know i have to know when to
fold them you know
when it's that time you know i left out
the game gracefully i didn't want to be
one of those people that's just still
out there still grinding
you know but you saved money oh yes
absolutely
but i don't knock the game if i see
somebody doing
what i used to do or whatever i don't
knock nobody or judge nobody
you know because i ate and i lived off
this money
for years and it's good money ain't
nothing like no home money whole money
is for show money
and drugs were a part of your life no
marijuana some hennessy
and keep it moving so how do you define
success
you think the money you make is enough
to
satisfy you and keep you happy or no you
always want more
you don't ne it's never enough money
it's never enough money like i'm retired
but i tell you the truth right now if i
walked out in that lobby
and it was a rich man a white man not
trying to
be funny was about to give me some money
baby i will pull it over for a band
and i'll be so quick before you can wink
your eye
cause i got that sunshine never had a
problem
satisfying a client but
um never say what you never would never
do like i said
if i went outside in that lobby right
now and somebody offered me the right
amount of money
i said i'm pulling it over man i'm
getting to it
and then and there's something about
this life the the attraction
from from men the fact that they're
willing to give you
a lot of money for what you do yeah it
builds your self-esteem
it's kind of against the vanity type of
thing too it makes you confident
i wouldn't say conceited confident like
i still got it
you know like when young boys try to get
at me like i'm
definitely like not like not a cougar i
would never be a cougar
i'm more of a fox you know if anything
they're going to get some wisdom from me
and i'm gonna brother em up or nephew
i'm up real quick i don't i don't play
those kind of games you know but
but for everything that's got an upside
there's a downside to it what what are
the rough sides of this
lifestyle getting robbed going crazy
um pardon me get depressed
get depressed um the only time i get
depressed about anything
is poverty i'm much of i'm a very happy
person all the time
i'm scared of poverty poverty yeah i
don't want to be broke
yeah yeah what do you think the most
misunderstood
thing is about this lifestyle you know
for for people outside of it
it seems like a very cold people judge
it
and think like oh we're some cruel
people we do this we do that
but like in the bible have you ever
heard of rahab
when she heard joshua and caleb and
right before they were going to take
over jericho and
and the soldiers came there and they
were like i i know that
somebody's been over here trying to you
know keep out our you know
scene and stuff like that she was like
yeah they were here and they got some
coochie
but they went that way when they really
went that way and god blessed her
you know so like i'm i'm saying that to
say this
home being going on for a long time and
it's never gonna stop
you know and rahab was blessed by god
and
she is one of the people in the bible
that has so much faith in god
that he loved her so much and she was
boaz mother so god took her away from
that game
and he made her a virtue woman and she
married somebody
in the hebrew army so is there
does it wear on you after a while
knowing that every guy every
other girl every cop every pimp every
everyone is kind of
looking out for themselves it's a doggy
dog world eat or be
ate you know i don't have thin skin
like somebody who has thin skin they
couldn't take it yeah this life's not
for everybody right it's not for
everybody have you seen girls that just
couldn't handle it
i see men that can't handle it
you got to have that janae say quoi you
know
and that's what i have like i said it's
a lot of extraordinary people
that's in this game you recall the very
first time you did this for money
i can remember the first day it was june
1st 1985
and i went to frisco and i came up on
500
and back in the day that's like a
thousand fifteen hundred
i thought it was hot [ __ ] and i was like
hanging with a group of little white
girls
italian girls you know so i was getting
really money i was like the black
girl in the group so i really benefited
off being around those white girls
you know if you can't beat them join her
what was the best time of your life
the best time of my life
oh i have so many great times i remember
like dc when uh kenny
man we was getting so much money that's
when marin barry was the mayor
when he got caught with the crack at
that time the police was cricket
everybody was crooked all they wanted
was their hands oiled
and that was one of the funnest times in
my life i used to have tricks lined
up like i would never get in the car
with them i would have the station wagon
and they would look for me my name was
tiffany back then they'd be like we want
tiffany we want tiffany
and i had blonde hair back then and
um that was one of the funnest times of
my life i just loved hoe and i was just
such a happy hooker
and then you know having such a good
pimp like kenny red
really made you happy because he was a
fun pimp like
you know we should go out to dinner he
used to take us all
out we used to go to the player's ball
he would have big birthday parties and
we would like whoever's getting the most
money and it was like a little
competition thing with my wife-in-laws
but it was not bad you know it was like
kind of healthy built your character
you know and who's gonna get the rawest
outfit but he made sure that we all were
treated equal
and um one thing kenny red never did
like pimps do
they put all their holes together trying
to save money and stuff like that
not kenny red not kenny red he have us
all in different hotels
you know like he don't like all that you
know and he would just be
bouncing around from different cities i
may be in hawaii
i may have a wife alone in vegas and i
might have a wife along miami or wife
along california
you know kenny red had like his first
string his second string
and then he had the third string which
was the dookie booties but you know
he still made them feel good about home
and they they weren't they weren't
really no lookers you know
but i was also you know i was all
definitely on the first string i was a
starter
but um i never warmed the bench just to
let you know that
what was the worst time of your life the
worst the worst time in my life
was um
thank god i never got raped or none of
that stuff like that because i'm a riot
myself
i just have a switchblade in my bra a
mace here
like i'm really pretty but i'm dangerous
hella dangerous and i know to throw
these paws bam bam bam
you know but anyway back to the lecture
at hand
the most depressed time of my life or
the worst
time of my life was
when
i was on the whole stroll and
i got really sick and i was scared for
my life and i got rushed to
a queens of angels hospital
and um i was having an optopic pregnancy
could you imagine that out on the whole
show in hollywood
but i'm hurting all day and i had an
optopic pregnancy
and then i um went to the hospital they
did surgery on me
this stupid doctor left surgical sponges
in my stomach
and before and they let me out the
hospital a week later
and then i just was really sick and then
i had to go back to the hospital
and i almost died so that was one of the
really scariest times of my life
i don't really have any scary times like
i was kidnapped by no tricks thank god
you know i had a trick one time pull a
gun on me
and i was like oh god like i was scared
and all of a sudden i snatched it out of
his hand
and i pulled it on him i was like you
gonna hurt somebody with this gun
and i opened up the door i was like get
out get out and i just pulled a gun on
him
you know i had some close calls you know
and um
i had a really really crazy experience
i had shut the whole whole show down in
van brewing
in phoenix it was a rookie police he um
tried to arrest me and he went in the
hotel to go get a room and i looked in
the glove compartment and seen his badge
and his gun
i took it all and i hid it in the
garbage outside the hotel
and then he got in the car and then we
pulled over and he tried to like block
me in but i jumped out the window before
he can get me
then he looked in his glove compartment
and his [ __ ] was gone
and do you know they shut the whole
stroll down everybody was mad at me
but i kept it and um got on a
bus and went back to another city and
stuff but
they wind up getting it like two years
later i'm not gonna tell you how
because i don't want to incriminate
myself but that was a crazy experience
you know
i know he got demoted but um
for the most part i'm a happy hooker and
kenny red pimping is good
and he was always good to all of his
hookers
and uh we always had nice cars we always
had nice places
you know and uh did you ever look back
at
your situation at your life and just go
man this is so nuts this is so crazy
it's so crazy sometimes i um regret not
taking um um opportunities for like you
know
music producers and uh you know movie
producers being in hollywood and stuff
i'm i'm a very attractive lady
and i have a very witty personality and
i used to get offered
so many different roles and do to do
different things but
i was just so sprung on kenny red
pimping that was against the rules so
i never let nobody like trick me up or
anything like that
and try to tell me you're too pretty for
this and i can help you do this and i
can help you do that
and i used to be like boy buy i got a
pimp to pay
and i you know i just my mind was just
straight on paying my pimp
so i did i do regret that in my life you
know
have i ever been in love i mean with my
daughter
with my daughter and with kenny red i
used to love kenny red last year dirty
draws and drink his dirty bath water
yeah for real he's somebody that you
could love you got a heart
bigger than texas like he had so much so
many [ __ ] and he treated us so good
and we all knew not to be jealous
can't be jealous or kenny red is going
to be upset
do you respect the men that that pick
you up
um do i respect her hell no
[ __ ] them funky ass tricks i'd be nice
you know what i'm saying just to get my
money but when they be johnny i'll be
praying that they hurry up
i'll be like you funky dirty ass funky
ass trick
this is the mouth you kiss your kids
with
hell no ain't got no respect for them
the [ __ ]
what do you wish was different about
your life do you have any regrets um i
told you me not taking the opportunities
that i could have been just like
totally rich but i just feel like it was
my destiny
you know and um it was written you know
this is what it is you know
i'm hustle mom that's who i am i'm the
whole fairy
i sprinkle these little young [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and let them
know the game because i didn't have
nobody to give me the game like them
because i paved the way for them what
advice would you give to a young girl
um a young girl who's thinking of doing
this i'll tell her to stack her money up
like
jenga you know what i'm saying stack
your money up
buy you some bitcoins you know um
just save your money give it to big mama
you know what i'm saying stay away from
drugs
never never ever go without rubbers i
don't care what they say i don't care if
it was the priest
saying that he don't even have sex he's
celebrating you're the first one
don't never go without a rubber and
that's what i'm thank god i ain't got no
diseases i'm you know i'm just
sucker-free
i'm so i'm one of god's favorite i know
i'm one of god's favorites because i
ain't never
i got my scruple still my throat ain't
been slashed
i never been took off robbed but i have
been tried to get took
off you know but it never seceded no
weapon formed against me shall prosper
you know it formed you know i had some
mexicans try to take me off at one time
and i just jumped in the passenger seat
and just gouged their eyes out
and we just had a car accident we ran
into a
car lot and when the police came they
were like you so lucky
it was like they didn't kill five girls
i was like they weren't about to drive
me to my death
i was kicking and screaming you ain't
about to drive me to my death
we all going out i'm going cosmicozzi on
your ass
and um you know that was a scary
experience too but you know i walked
away with no scratch maybe
i lost a heel but i didn't have they
didn't get my money
they didn't get my money you know
but what's the most important lesson the
most the lesson i learned and i've seen
other women do
i'm not saying from my perspective
a lesson that okay i'm just not going to
talk about nobody else the lesson that
i've learned
a lesson that i've learned
drop your books lose your lessons
yeah drop your books lose your lessons
you can't be dropping your books you
can't be slipping like you got banana
peels up
under your feet you know you got to be
on your toes you got to look
you know watch every way and look ahead
and be 10 steps ahead
you can't be slow joe and uh
that's my advice yeah all right martina
thank you so much for sharing your story
have fun at the players ball tonight yes
i will and uh
thank you so much
that was awesome
great